WE WILL SEE YOU BACK HERE
TOMORROW.
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
NOT MANY PEOPLE ARE SAYING IT
OUT LOUD ON THE RIGHT, BUT THE
FACT IS THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
COULD WELL LOSE THIS ELECTION.
IN FACT, AND LESS FUNDAMENTAL
FACTS CHANGE SOON, IT COULD BE
TOUGH FOR HIM TO BE REELECTED.
THE PRESIDENT DOES LOSE, THAT
MEANS JUST A FEW MONTHS FROM
NOW, JOE BIDEN WOULD BECOME THE
PRESIDENT.
THE UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT
WOULD FALL INTO THE CONTROL OF
THE RADICALS WHO CONTROLLED
JOE BIDEN AND THEY WILL REMAKE
THE COUNTRY.
NOW, WE ARE FULLY AWARE THAT
VIRTUALLY NOBODY WATCHING THE
SHOW TONIGHT WANTS TO HEAR THAT,
BUT IT’S TRUE, AND KEY PEOPLE
AROUND THE PRESIDENT KNOW THAT
IT’S TRUE.
THEY’VE SEEN THE NUMBERS, AND
THEY ARE CONCERNED.
AT SOME POINT IN THE FUTURE,
HISTORIANS WILL MARVEL AT THE
FACT THAT THE PRESIDENT LOST
GROUND DURING A PANDEMIC AND
THEN DURING MASS RIOTS.
BOTH CRISES SHOULD HAVE
HIGHLIGHTED THIS.
ALONE AMONG NATIONAL LEADERS,
DONALD TRUMP WARNED AMERICANS
FOR DECADES ABOUT CHINA AND THE
PERILS OF GLOBALIZATION.
EVERYTHING ABOUT THE WUHAN
CORONAVIRUS PROVED DONALD TRUMP
RIGHT.
CHINA REALLY IS OUR MAIN GLOBAL
ADVERSARY PAIR THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT REALLY DOES WANT TO
TAKE OVER THE WORLD.
MEANWHILE, THE FACT THAT WE SENT
OUR MANUFACTURING BASE OF A BROA
REALLY WEAKENED US.
NO LONGER MAKES ANTIBIOTICS,
MAYBE WE ARE NOT AS POWERFUL AS
WE THINK.
ALL OF THAT IS VERY OBVIOUS NOW
AFTER THE PANDEMIC, BUT
DONALD TRUMP CALLED IT.
YOU THINK VOTERS WOULD REWARD
HIM FOR THAT.
YOU THE RIOTS WOULD HAVE CREASED
THEIR SUPPORT FOR HIM.
AN AWFUL LOT OF PEOPLE VOTED FOR
DONALD TRUMP PRECISELY TO AVOID
A MOMENT WE ARE NOW IN.
NONE OF THIS ARRIVE SUDDENLY, WE
SAW IT COMING.
SUCH COHESION IN AMERICA HAS
BEEN ERODING FOR DECADES.
MADE THEM NERVOUS, SHOULD MAKE
THEM NERVOUS.
DONALD TRUMP SEEMS LIKE
INSURANCE AGAINST THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THAT.
THE COURT APPEAL OF TRUMP WAS OF
THINGS EVER STARTED TO FALL
APART, HE WOULD DEFEND YOU.
YES, HE WAS LOUD AND CRUDE.
MOST BODYGUARDS ARE.
ONLY A MAN LIKE DONALD TRUMP WAS
TOUGH ENOUGH TO FIGHT THE
CREEPING AUTHORITARIANISM OF THE
EDUCATION CARTEL IN CORPORATE
AMERICA.
TRUMP GOT ELECTED, YOU COULD SAY
WHAT YOU REALLY BELIEVE, THE
BASIC PROMISE OF AMERICA COULD
BE RESTORED.
HE COULD LIVE WITH DIGNITY.
UNDER DONALD TRUMP, YOU WOULDN’T
BE FORCED TO MOUNT THE LYRICS TO
SOME REPULSIVE ORTHODOXY YOU
HATE.
YOU COULD DECLARE OUT LOUD THAT
ALL LIVES MATTER BECAUSE ALL
LIVES DO MATTER.
GOD MADE US ALL, AND IF YOU
CAN’T SAY THAT, WHAT’S THE POINT
OF LIVING HERE?
DONALD TRUMP NEVER QUITE
ARTICULATED ANY OF THIS IN A
PRECISE WAY.
HE IS NOT AN INTELLECTUAL OR AN
IDEOLOGUE BUT IT’S OBVIOUS HE
FELT STRONGLY.
HIS GUT LEVEL INSTINCTS WERE ON
THE SIDE OF ORDER AND TRADITION
AND STABILITY, AND THEY STILL
ARE.
AND YET, WHEN WIDESPREAD LOOTING
AND DISORDER ARRIVED, THE
PRESIDENT DID NOT ACT AS
DECISIVELY AS MANY HAD HOPED.
HE SAID LITTLE, HE DID LAST.
SOME VOTERS FELT UNDEFENDED.
SOME TURNED AGAINST HIM.
WHY DID THIS HAPPEN?
THERE ARE MANY REASONS.
TRUMP WAS EXHAUSTED AFTER THREE
YEARS OF DEFENDING HIMSELF
AGAINST RUSSIA GATE, THE MOST
ELABORATE AND EFFECTIVE HOAX IN
AMERICAN HISTORY AND HIS STAFF
DID NOT MUCH TO HELP.
IN SOME OF THEM WERE ACTIVELY
DISLOYAL AND MOST WERE CONFUSED.
THEY DEFINITELY WERE NOT
PREPARED FOR CHINESE VIRUSES ARE
BURNING CITIES, BUT THE
ADMINISTRATION’S MAIN PROBLEMS
WERE CONCEPTUAL.
FEW SEEM TO UNDERSTAND WHAT WAS
REALLY HAPPENING.
THEIR FIRST MISTAKE WAS
FORGETTING THE PRIMARY RULE OF
WASHINGTON.
IN AN ELECTION YEAR, EVERYTHING
THAT HAPPENS IS ABOUT THE
ELECTION.
THEY WERE NO EXCEPTIONS TO THAT
RULE.
WASHINGTON IS A POLITICAL CITY
RUN BY POLITICIANS.
THE CHINESE NAVY SAILED UP THE
POTOMAC IN THE FALL OF AN
ELECTION YEAR, THE FIRST THING
MOST PEOPLE IN D.C. WOULD WONDER
IS HOW WAS I GOING TO AFFECT
TURNOUT?
THAT’S WHO THEY ARE.
IT’S HOW THEY THINK.
SO ONLY THE NAIVE ARE SURPRISED
WHEN DEMOCRATIC GOVERNORS
IMMEDIATELY USE THE CORONAVIRUS
QUARANTINES TO PUNISH PEOPLE WHO
DIDN’T VOTE FOR THEM.
IN CHRISTIAN CHURCHES AND SMALL
BUSINESSES WERE LOCKED DOWN, WE
CHOPS AN ABORTION CLINIC STAYED
OPEN.
MOST TRUMP VOTERS SEEM NOT TO
NOTICE.
THEY ACCEPTED THE RESTRICTIONS
WITHOUT QUESTION.
THIS WAS A HEALTH CRISIS AND
THEY WANTED TO DO THE RIGHT
THING, SO THEY OBEYED.
THEY COWERED IN THEIR HOMES, AND
THAT’S EXACTLY WERE DEMOCRATIC
LEADERS WANTED THEM.
CUT OFF FROM ONE ANOTHER,
ATOMIZED, AND ALONE.
THE FEW CONSERVATIVES WHO TRY TO
ORGANIZE RESISTANCE TO THE
LOCKDOWNS WERE INDICTED OR
THREATENED WITH ARREST.
NONE OF THIS HAD ANYTHING TO DO
WITH PUBLIC HEALTH, OF COURSE.
WAS ELECTORAL POLITICS AND AN
ESPECIALLY BRUTAL FORM OF IT.
REPUBLICAN LEADERS MEANWHILE
WERE REMARKABLY SLOW TO CATCH ON
TO WHAT WAS HAPPENING.
SOME OF THEM AREN’T VERY BRIGHT
BUT MOST JUST COULDN’T IMAGINE
ANYONE ACTING WITH THAT LEVEL OF
CYNICISM AND RUTHLESSNESS.
THEIR GOOD FAITH MADE THEM
VULNERABLE TO THEIR OPPONENT’S
LIES.
WERE USED.
IN THE DAYS AFTER GEORGE FLOYD
DIED, THE SAME TRENDS
ACCELERATED DRAMATICALLY.
ALL HAPPENED SO FAST THAT IT
SEEMS LIKE CHAOS AT THE TIME,
BUT IT WASN’T CHAOS.
IT WAS DESIGNED JUST BENEATH THE
SURFACE.
CONSIDER THE TARGETS OF THE MOB
CHOSE.
LAW ENFORCEMENT, OBVIOUSLY, BUT
NOT ALL LAW ENFORCEMENT.
LOCAL POLICE DEPARTMENTS MUST BE
ELIMINATED, THEY SAID, BUT THE
FBI IS JUST FINE AND THAT WAS
TELLING.
THEN THEY CLAIMED THAT
CAPITALISM WAS THE ENEMY, BUT
ONLY CERTAIN KINDS OF
CAPITALISM.
THE MOB BURNED INDEPENDENT
BUSINESSES TO THE GROUND BY THE
SCORE AND DIDN’T SAY A WORD
ABOUT THOSE BUSINESSES DIGITAL
COMPETITORS, GOOGLE, APPLE, AND
AMAZON.
ALL OF THOSE COMPANIES WERE
FINDING THE DESTRUCTION.
THEN THE MOB TOLD US THAT
TRADITIONAL CHRISTIANITY WAS
RACIST.
THEY DESECRATED CHURCHES IN THE
NAME OF AVENGING SLAVERY YET
ANTIFA DID NOT TOUCH A SINGLE
MOSQUE DESPITE THE FACT THAT
HISTORIANS SAY MUHAMMAD OWNED.
AS ALL THIS PROGRESS, DEMOCRATS
CONTINUE THEIR LECTURES ABOUT
GUN CONTROL, AS THEY ALWAYS DO.
BUT THEY IGNORE THE RIFLES IN
THE HANDS OF THEIR OWN
SUPPORTERS IN DOWNTOWN SEATTLE.
THE REAL THREAT, THEY TOLD US,
WAS RURAL AMERICANS WITH THEIR
AR-15s.
THAT OR GET THE FBI ON THAT,
ARREST MORE FARMERS.
IN OTHER WORDS, WHAT LOOKED LIKE
PROTEST WERE HIGHLY EFFECTIVE
ATTACKS ON DONALD TRUMP’S
VOTERS, HIS POWER BASE.
FEW IN WASHINGTON CLEARLY
APPRECIATED THIS AT LEAST ON THE
RIGHT.
THEY HAD, THEY WOULD’VE TOLD THE
COUNTRY WHAT WAS REALLY
HAPPENING.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT GEORGE FLOYD,
NOT ABOUT POLICE BRUTALITY.
IS A POWER GRAB BY A VIOLENT
EXTREMIST BUT THEY DIDN’T
UNDERSTAND THAT.
SO WEEKS INTO THE RIOTING, THE
SOCIAL MEDIA ACCOUNTS AT THE
WHITE HOUSE WERE STILL PRODUCING
HAM-HANDED POSTS ABOUT
JUNETEENTH.
NO ONE WAS CONVINCED BY THEM, NO
ONE WAS REASSURED.
INSTEAD, MANY VOTERS ARE
BECOMING INCREASINGLY AGITATED
BY THE LAWLESSNESS THEY SAW ALL
AROUND THEM.
WHO IS GOING TO PROTECT US FROM
THIS, THEY WONDERED.
THE SOCIAL MEDIA ACCOUNTS DID
NOTHING TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION.
WE WANT TO PLAY FOR YOU TO
PIECES OF TAPE THAT HELP
ILLUSTRATE WHAT LIFE IS LIKE FOR
MANY AMERICANS RIGHT NOW.
NEITHER ONE OF THESE SHOWS
GRAPHIC VIOLENCE.
WE CAN FIND TAPE THAT DOES SHOW
IT.
BUT WHAT WE ARE GOING TO PLAY
INSTEAD FOR YOU IS IN SOME WAYS
MORE INSIDIOUS THAN ASSAULT.
WHAT YOU WILL HEAR IS NEGLECT
AND NEGLECT IS ITSELF A FORM OF
VIOLENCE.
THE FIRST TAPE IS FROM A SMALL
TOWN, FREDERICKSBURG VIRGINIA.
A 911 CALL RECORDED EARLIER THIS
MONTH.
A WOMAN TOOK HER YOUNG DAUGHTER
ON AARON’S DOWNTOWN.
AS THE TWO TRIED TO DRIVE HOME,
A MOB SURROUNDED THEIR VEHICLE
AND BLOCKED IT FROM MOVING.
TERRIFIED, CALLED 911 AND HERE
IS THE RESPONSE SHE GOT.
>> THEY ARE ON MY CAR.
THEY ARE ON MY CAR RIGHT NOW.
>> I WOULD SUGGEST YOU SLOWLY
DRIVE THROUGH THE AREA.
>> I CANNOT GET OUT OF HERE.
>> BE PATIENT, I WILL LET THE
OFFICERS KNOW, OKAY?
>> ARE YOU SERIOUS?
>> WE CAN’T DO ANYTHING, MA’AM.
THE STATE TOLD US THIS IS A
SANCTIONED EVENT.
>> THIS IS MY CAR.
I’VE GOT A KID HERE.
WE MET WE WOULD SUGGEST HE
CALLED UP CITY HALL LET THEM
KNOW YOUR FRUSTRATIONS.
>> GET OFF THE ROAD!
THIS IS SCARY!
THEY ARE ON MY CAR!
I HAVE A LITTLE GIRL IN THE CAR
CRYING, ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
>> Tucker: THEY ARE ON MY CAR,
THEY ARE ON MY CAR.
MA’AM, COMES THE REPLY, WE WOULD
SUGGEST YOU CALL UP CITY HALL TO
LET THEM KNOW ABOUT YOUR
FRUSTRATIONS.
THOSE ARE VERBATIM QUOTES.
IT’S HARD TO LISTEN TO THAT TAPE
WITHOUT FEELING EMOTIONAL.
A WOMAN AND HER CHILD WERE
TERRORIZED BY A VIOLENT MOB.
AND THEN THEY WERE INTENTIONALLY
ABANDONED BY THE STATE THAT HAS
PROMISED TO PROTECT THEM.
WAS THE ULTIMATE BETRAYAL OF
CITIZENSHIP.
YOU SHOULD KNOW THAT THE MAYOR
OF FREDERICKSBURG VIRGINIA LATER
APOLOGIZED, BUT DID NOT
APOLOGIZE TO TARA DURRANT OR HER
YOUNG DAUGHTER.
THE MAYOR APOLOGIZED TO THE MOB.
POLICE HAD TRIED TO DISPERSE
THEM WHILE THEY WERE RIDING.
"I AM PERSONALLY SORRY.
I WANT TO APOLOGIZE TO THOSE WHO
WENT THROUGH THIS FEARFUL
EXPERIENCE.
AGAIN, TO BE CRYSTAL CLEAR, SHE
SAID THAT THE RIOTERS I’M NOT TO
THE CITIZENS SHE HAD CRUELLY
ABANDONED.
ALL OF THAT HAPPENED IN A LITTLE
TOWN OF 25,000 PEOPLE.
AND IT’S HAPPENING IN SO MANY
AMERICAN TOWNS RIGHT NOW.
HERE’S WHAT’S HAPPENING IN OUR
CITIES.
THIS IS A RECENT VIDEO YORK.
LOOKS LIKE A FOREIGN COUNTRY.
AS HE WATCHED, NOTICE HOW THE
POLICE RESPOND.
THE SQUAD CAR JUST ROLLS ON
THROUGH, COPS DON’T EVEN SLOW
DOWN.
THEY’VE BEEN TOLD NOT TO.
THEY DON’T TRY TO ENFORCE THE
LAW.
THEY CAN’T ENFORCE THE LAW.
KEEP IN MIND DECENT PEOPLE LIVE
IN THAT NEIGHBORHOOD.
DECENT PEOPLE LIVE IN EVERY
AMERICAN NEIGHBORHOOD.
HOW WOULD YOU FEEL IF YOU LIVED
THERE?
YOU’D BE VERY AFRAID.
HE’D FEEL LIKE THINGS WERE
FALLING APART.
MORE THAN ANYTHING ELSE, YOU
WOULD WANT SOMEONE TO RESTORE
ORDER.
WANT THEM TO TAKE BACK YOUR
NEIGHBORHOOD FROM ARMS CHILDREN
BECAUSE ARMED CHILDREN ARE FAR
MORE THREATENING THAN EVEN THE
WORST ROGUE COP, ALWAYS.
IN THE LOCAL LEADERS ARE NOT
DOING THAT.
THEY ARE NOT RESTORING ORDER,
THEY ARE IGNORING THE SUFFERING
OF THEIR PEOPLE.
SO WHAT IS THE WHITE HOUSE DOING
ABOUT THIS?
THE PRESIDENT ANNOUNCED THAT
ANYONE WHO TOPPLES A STATUE ON
FEDERAL PROPERTY WILL FACE TEN
YEARS IN PRISON.
THAT IS A WELCOME START.
WHAT WE ARE LIVING THROUGH RIGHT
NOW DESPITE WHAT PEOPLE HAVE
TOLD YOU IS NOT A LOCAL PROBLEM.
THIS IS A NATIONAL CRISIS.
THE RIOTS ARE DESIGNED TO
PRODUCE A NATIONAL RESULT.
THE DESTRUCTION OF OUR SYSTEM OF
GOVERNMENT AND THE REMOVAL OF
DONALD TRUMP.
PEOPLE EXPECT A PRESIDENT TO
RESPOND TO A MOMENT LIKE THIS TO
FIX IT AND THEY HAVE A RIGHT TO
EXPECT THAT.
THE PRESIDENT RUNS THE COUNTRY.
THE RIOTERS WERE SAUDI
NATIONALS, IT WOULD BE VERY
CLEAR THERE WAS NOTHING LOCAL
ABOUT WHAT WE ARE WATCHING.
HE WOULD UNDERSTAND IMMEDIATELY
IT IS TERRORISM.
IN THE PRESIDENT WOULD GIVE A
PRIME TIME ADDRESS.
WITHIN HOURS, THE FEDS WOULD BE
HUNTING THESE PEOPLE DOWN AND
ARRESTING THEM.
THEY WOULD BE IN PRISON FACING
LIFE.
SO THE QUESTION IS, WHY ISN’T
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
RESPONDING LIKE THIS?
IT’S NOT CLEAR.
ASSEMBLING THE WHITE HOUSE
COUNSEL’S OFFICE DOMINATED BY
BUSH PARTISANS WHO ARE HOSTILE
TO TRAUMA.
WE DON’T KNOW IF THAT’S TRUE.
IT IS TRUE, THERE’S AN EASY
SOLUTION TO IT, JUST IGNORE
THEIR COUNSEL.
SEND THEM TO THE BASEMENT AND
HAVE THEM REORGANIZE THE CARD
CATALOG OR READ
"READER’S DIGEST" FROM THE
’70s.
ONLY A FOOL LETS THEM MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS ANYWAY.
THEY WERE, THEY WOULDN’T BE
LAWYERS.
OTHERS SAY BUREAUCRATS AT THE
DOJ OR FEDERAL PROSECUTORS IN
THE STATES ARE DRAGGING THEIR
FEET.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL BILL BARR
SAYS HE IS OVERSEEING 500
SEPARATE INVESTIGATIONS INTO
RIOTERS.
GOOD FOR HIM.
PRESUMABLY ONE OF THEM IN
WASHINGTON, TOOK PLACE LAST
SATURDAY IT WAS ON LIVE
TELEVISION.
SO FAR, NO ONE HAS BEEN ARRESTED
FOR IT.
WOULD CHANGE THE COURSE OF THIS
COUNTRY’S FUTURE IF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT ROUNDED UP THE
LEADERS OF ANTI-FOR TOMORROW
ALONG WITH EVERY SINGLE PERSON
CAUGHT ON CAMERA TORCHING A
BUILDING, DESTROYING A MONUMENT,
DEFACING A CHURCH, AND PUT THEM
ALL IN SHACKLES AND THEN MARCH
THEM IN FRONT OF CAMERAS LIKE
MS-13 AND CALL THEM WHAT THEY
ACTUALLY ARE, DOMESTIC
TERRORISTS.
NOT PROTESTERS, NOT CIVIL RIGHTS
ACTIVIST, NOT CNN CONTRIBUTORS,
BUT DOMESTIC TERRORISTS.
AND THAT WOULD BE THEIR NEW
GOVERNMENT APPROVED TITLE.
ONCE THEY ARE CHARGED, IT’S
OFFICIAL, IN FACT.
THEY ARE LITERALLY AS A FACTUAL
MATTER ACCUSED TERRORISTS, AND
THAT WOULD CHANGE MINDS RIGHT
AWAY.
THE PEOPLE DESTROYING THIS
COUNTRY ARE CRIMINALS, IF YOU
ARE BRAVE ENOUGH TO CALL THEM
THAT SO NATURALLY THEIR
POPULARITY GROWS.
EVERYONE SUPPORTS PROTESTERS.
THIS IS AMERICA.
WE BELIEVE IN PROTESTS, BUT
WATCH WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU
START CALLING THEM WHAT THEY
REALLY ARE.
MOST PEOPLE DON’T LIKE
TERRORISTS.
TERRORISTS WILL NEVER BE POPULAR
EVEN AMONG DEMOCRATIC VOTERS.
SO CHARGE THEM FOR THE CRIMES
THEY’VE COMMITTED AND CALL THEM
WHAT THEY ARE.
RIGHT NOW, THE OPPOSITE IS
HAPPENING.
THE TERRORISTS ARE MORE POPULAR
THAN THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES AND NOT JUST MORE
POPULAR THAN DONALD TRUMP
PERSONALLY, BUT MORE POPULAR
THAN THE SYSTEM HE REPRESENTS
AND ADMINISTERS, AND IT IS
OBVIOUS WHY.
OUR SYSTEM IS WEAK.
REFUSES TO DEFEND ITSELF.
MAYORS LET NEW COUNTRY SPROUT IN
THE MIDDLE OF THEIR CITIES.
OUR LEADERS ACT LIKE LAWS ARE
IRRELEVANT.
EVERYONE WATCHES THIS HAPPENED.
IT’S A POTENTIALLY FATAL PROBLEM
PROBLEM.
WEAK INSTITUTIONS DIE, CITIZENS
DEVELOP CONTEMPT FOR THEM AND
THEN MAKE IT OVERTHROWN.
THE SAME IS TRUE FOR HEADS OF
STATE.
WHEN YOU REFUSE TO FIGHT FOR THE
SYSTEM YOU RUN, YOU ARE DONE.
SPEND AN HOUR ON GOOGLE AND SEE
IF YOU CAN FIND A SINGLE LEADER
IN THE HISTORY OF THE WORLD WHO
STAYED IN POWER AFTER FAILING TO
FOLLOW REBELLION.
YOU CAN’T.
THE SADDEST PART OF ALL OF THIS
IS OUR SYSTEM IS VERY MUCH WORTH
SAVING.
ADMINISTERS JUSTICE MORE FAIRLY
THAN ANY SYSTEM IN THE WORLD.
WE WANT TO KEEP THAT SYSTEM, WE
HAVE TO USE THAT SYSTEM, AND
THAT MEANS ENFORCING AMERICANS
LAWS WITH CERTAINTY, ENFORCING
THEM RIGHT NOW AT THE MOMENT OF
GREATEST PERIL.
WE DON’T DO IT NOW, WE NEVER
WILL DO IT.
THEY IGNORE A LAW LONG ENOUGH
AND IT BECOMES UNENFORCEABLE.
HE WOULD BE SHOCKED IF YOU GOT
PULLED OVER FOR DOING 58 AND A
55-MILE-AN-HOUR ZONE, OBVIOUSLY.
NT FEDS LEADERS WOULD BE SHOCKED
IF THEY WERE ARRESTED FOR
DESTROYING A STATUE OF
ABRAHAM LINCOLN.
JUST A MONTH AGO, DESTROYING
STATUES WAS A FELONY.
NOW, IT’S ALLOWED.
WHERE WILL HE BE A MONTH FROM
NOW?
WHAT WILL WILL WE ALLOW BY NOVEM
THE PLANE AS THINGS CHANGE FAST
AND THAT INCLUDE SOCIAL
STANDARDS, THEY CHANGE VERY
QUICKLY TOO APPEAR JUST A FEW
WEEKS AGO, IT SOUNDED LIKE A
CRACKPOT IDEA AND NOW IT’S
HAPPENING.
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS SUPPORT IT
IT.
MANY REPUBLICAN OFFICEHOLDERS
HAVEN’T THOUGHT VERY DEEPLY
ABOUT WHY THIS IS EVEN NOW, YOU
WILL SEE THEM GRIN AT THE LATEST
INSANITY FROM THE LEFT.
CAN YOU BELIEVE THIS?
THEY’VE GONE TOO FAR THIS TIME.
THERE’S GOING TO BE A BACKLASH.
WHEN EXACTLY WILL THAT BACKLASH
ARRIVED?
BECAUSE THE OPPOSITE SEEMS TO BE
HAPPENING.
WHAT SEEMED AWFUL THE OTHER DAY
IS NORMAL NOW.
TURNS OUT THAT IF YOU DON’T
BOTHER TO EXPLAIN PRECISELY WHY
CERTAIN IDEAS ARE BAD, IF YOU
DON’T VIGOROUSLY DEFEND YOUR OWN
WORLDVIEW, THEN YOU LOSE.
BAD IDEAS SPREAD, THEY QUICKLY
CONGEAL INTO CONVENTIONAL
WISDOM, AND THEN YOU ARE DONE.
THIS IS ESPECIALLY TRUE RIGHT
NOW WHEN EVERYTHING IN AMERICAN
LIFE IS UP FOR GRABS.
THE LOCKDOWNS SHUFFLE THE DECK
COMPLETELY.
FOUR MONTHS AGO, YOU’D ASSUME
YOU WOULD SPEND THE NEXT 20
YEARS GOING INTO AN OFFICE
SOMEWHERE AND NOW YOU ARE
WORKING FROM YOUR COUCH STARTING
TO CONSIDER MOVING TO BOZEMAN
AND WHY WOULDN’T YOU AND WHILE
WE ARE AT IT, WHAT ELSE SHOULD
WE DO DIFFERENTLY?
NORMAL PEOPLE ARE STARTING TO
THINK LIKE THIS.
ONCE BIG THINGS START CHANGING,
THEY TEND TO CHANGE MORE QUICKLY
THAN WE EXPECT.
ALL OF THIS MEANS THIS IS
PRECISELY THE TIME RIGHT NOW
TONIGHT TO DEFEND THE
INSTITUTIONS THAT WE DESPERATELY
NEED TO KEEP IN THIS COUNTRY.
THOSE INSTITUTIONS INCLUDE THE
NUCLEAR FAMILY, OUR FREEDOM OF
SPEECH, SMALL, INDEPENDENT
BUSINESSES, ABSOLUTE
COLORBLINDNESS UNDER THE LAW.
THE NOBLE TRADITION OF
NONVIOLENT PROTEST.
THOSE OF THE THINGS THAT MAKE US
PROUD TO BE AMERICANS.
THOSE ARE THE THINGS THAT MAKE
AMERICA A PLACE WORTH LIVING IN.
WE NEED TO DEFEND THESE THINGS
WITH EVERYTHING WE HAVE, ALL OF
US MUST DEFEND THEM INCLUDING
THE PRESIDENT.
THAT IS HIS HOPE OF REELECTION.